- Now, let me state
what I'm going to do.
The big question I'm
trying to get at is this.
What do we mean when
we say the "flight
to heaven" in early China?
What is heaven?
Is there really
"up there" there?
So the best case to state
this issue is the following.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- In 1974, some farmers
digging a new well
in the shadow of a strange
hill collided with history.
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
- For at the bottom
of that simple well
stood the army of
the mighty Qin,
still leading their
emperor into eternity.
[SUSPENSFUL MUSIC]
[END PLAYBACK]
- 8,000 terracotta
warriors, none of them
look alike, what for?
The army, as the film states,
is leading their emperor
into eternity.
Really?
Well, we don't want to
beat up on the filmmakers
because I love film makers.
I think the scholars are to be
blamed for this misinformation.
So what I'm going to
do today is really to--
I hope-- set the
record straight.
The common explanation of the
presence of terracotta army
is that it is there
to defend the tomb.
Again, really?
Now, just give you
a little background,
this is the Qin state.
And it actually came
from very humble origin
and was actually considered
barbarian in comparison
with all the six
states to the east.
The six states are more
cultured, more civilized,
whereas the Qin started as a
sort of backward backwater.
But then because they
instituted the political reform
and the rule of by law,
they eventually took over
and then annexed the
land of China in 221 BC.
And as soon as the emperor--
initially a young prince
who stepped into the throne
at the age of 13--
ascended to the throne, the
construction of the mausoleum
started.
And it took about four
decades to finish,
so it has been a long
haul for this monuments
to come to being.
Now, oddities abound
about this tomb complex.
The foremost question is this.
What again, was the
terracotta army for?
If the army is there to
defend the emperor's tomb,
why is it located so far off--
one mile away-- from the tomb?
If defense was their mission,
why the so-called warriors
are not in a combat
ready condition?
For one thing, none
of them wear helmets.
Not for lack of helmet
at the site, only
they seem to be misplaced
as if deliberately kept away
from the warriors.
Piles of helmets are stored in
an auxiliary pit immediately
east of the tomb mound.
Made of stone, they are not
meant to be actually worn.
So we have a curious situation.
The soldiers are deprived
of helmets for a reason.
The helmets are kept
away from the warriors
in permanent storage.
Very likely, the message
seems to be-- peace reigns
in this land, or in this world.
There's no need for
military action,
so the helmets are put away.
But then, there's
really no question
that the terracotta
figures are what they are.
That is, they are
soldiers, warriors,
only they are not
ready to fight.
If the army is not there
to fight, what is it for?
Or what is it good for?
There are more mysteries.
The defense theory
says that the army
is there to defend the tomb.
And then to the west
side of the tomb
archaeologists found
two bronze carriages
and now commonly believed to be
emperor's spirit vehicle that
takes him to heaven.
So the situation is
basically like this.
The commander-in-chief
says, soldiers
I really appreciate
you defending me,
now I'm leaving you.
So they essentially
beat their ways and head
into different directions.
So apparently you can
see that the defense
theory doesn't quite hold.
So the key to unlock the
all this set of mysteries
actually lies in an auxiliary
burial pit right here.
The army was there.
The pit is here to the
southeast of the tomb mount.
The pit contains 24 or so
life size, or even larger
than life, terracotta figures.
Apparent upper bare
torso in sharp contrast
with the terracotta warriors
one mile to the east.
So what you have here is
actually an oxymoron--
that these figures
are now commonly
believed to be acrobats.
Indeed, they are.
But then, they are
really solid acrobat,
very serious acrobat, which
is essentially an oxymoron.
Acrobats are
supposed to make fun
but there they are,
all in a straight face.
And then there is this bronze
vessel found in the pit.
By its size and
weight it is certainly
the most stately ritual vessel
of the land in this time.
Now, bronze vessels
are ceremonial objects
often associated with temple
offerings and other ritual
occasions.
As such, their
symbolic significance
derives from their
physical size, weight,
and refined decoration.
Now, the cauldron here
is weighty enough,
but it is really a
sort of odd piece out.
According to the
early ritual manual,
there's a hierarchy in
the number of vessels
that you are entitled for use.
So the common gentry,
the gentleman,
is entitled to one vessel.
The vassal state rulers
are entitled to three,
ministers of state entitled
to five, son of heaven--
that is emperor--
entitled to nine.
But here we actually have
the curious situation
that the emperor
receives only one vessel,
which obviously
his doesn't quite
square with the ritual theory.
So again, we have a problem of
what is the cauldron here for?
There are three
prevailing theories.
One is that the
vessel is there--
initially belonged to
an ancestral temple,
and in the time of
crisis, a wartime crisis,
it was in haste
moved to this pit.
The second theory
is that it is part
of a ritual ceremony,
in which case
it expands the seriousness
of these acrobats.
The third theory is no, no,
no, they the whole thing
is just entertainment for
the afterlife emperor.
Now, we can basically
eliminate all three theories
very quickly.
The first one
obviously doesn't hold.
If it's a serious
temple object, you
don't want to put it in the
company of mere acrobats.
It should have received
more serious placement.
If it's a funeral, then
you're hard-pressed to explain
the presence of the acrobats.
And if you stick
to the acrobats,
you then find yourself struggle
to explain the cauldron.
So essentially you have
this impossible situation,
either way it
doesn't quite work.
So I guess the bottom line
is-- the baseline is--
we have to find a
way to explain both
the cauldron and the acrobats.
And if we can do that, then
we have a key to this problem.
So fortunately I have--
and this is, I guess,
in my discovery--
I have found this
sarcophagus near contemporary
to the site that has both the
cauldron and the sarcophagus.
So if we can unlock the secret
here in this sarcophagus,
then we have a way of
explaining why is it
that the cauldron and the
acrobatics belong together.
Now, the sarcophagus is carved
on both in and out of faces.
And in the interest
of time, I'm not
going to take you through
all the iconographic
identification, which
is the sort of thing
we art historians
make a living on.
So I'll just present
you with the finding.
So the finding is essentially
that what you have here
is a seasonal cycle.
Now, why seasonal cycle?
More precisely, what
is the relevance
of the seasonal cycle
to a sarcophagus
intended to hold a dead body?
Now, implicit here is actually
the early Chinese understanding
of individual body and
its post-mortem existence.
To begin with, the body is
just a vessel and the system.
What makes life
possible is the key--
vital energy, or breath.
The enemy is both
the natural world
out there and the human body.
The breath manifests itself
in the seasonal cycle.
The key also consists of
both yin and yang energies,
two key components.
In springtime the
yang energy grows,
reaching its apex in summer.
Subsequently, that
yin energy grows,
hitting the nadir in winter.
The system is expressed in a
more abstract set of notations
that Chinese devised to describe
the broader range of phenomena,
and this set consists
of eight trigrams.
So you would have the
Zhen, Li, Dui, Kan.
Now, a trigram is--
as you can see--
consists of essentially two
line, well, three lines,
but of two kinds.
One is the broken line,
another is the continuous line.
So essentially,
the way it works is
rather like the computer
language, on and off,
and with that you can account
for a variety of phenomena.
In fact, this
whole trigram thing
is really a
computational device.
Now, I wouldn't bore you
with all the elaborate detail
of how this complex
system works but suffice
to call attention to trigrams,
Li on top, and Kan below.
Now, the whole point of having
this kind of abstract system
or scheme is that it can
be used to describe a range
of phenomenon and things.
So take for example, the word,
the notion, the concept of Kan
that is used here.
It can mean a list of things.
In fact, the list
can go on forever.
So largely it's north, winter,
water, kidney, essence.
And this whole system also works
by way of binary relations.
So you can just flip
this to describe what's
opposite in regard to Li.
So that's how this
whole thing works.
Now, if we plucked this
into the set of values
into the bodily
system, we see how
all early Chinese conception of
the body is not about the body.
It is really a
network of values.
They are reference points.
The network allows
for the conception
of body as both a physical
frame and the ecology
of natural elements.
The Kan trigram that
you see here, the trike,
actually points to
a set of qualities--
water, nadir, kidney, winter,
and so on and so forth.
To the extent that it
has a water quality,
it feeds on the body
as a imaginary ecology,
pumping up the water,
as you can see here.
So the spinal track is where
you pump your energy up
to the brain area.
And they call it pumping up the
water, the essence, whatever,
from the kidney region
up to the brain area
where it nourishes
the vitality and makes
the body's system functional.
Now, the Kan department--
and we can call it
a department because the
Chinese have this way of mapping
bureaucracy into everything.
So this Kan department
provides the energy source,
often visualized as a ding.
Vessel, as you can see here.
That is this tripart quadrant
that Chinese call ding.
Here the Chi or breath
is processed and turned
into a vital energies.
The process is one of
physiological alchemy,
also called a
inner alchemy, that
is a physiological
process modeled
upon the heart of
physical alchemy.
Now, if we mapped this onto
the sarcophagus carving,
we can see how this
whole bodily system
works by way of seasonal cycle.
But also this is where
we also find a ding,
the quadrant, the vessel.
Here, right here.
But the question also
is why is this ding--
this particular ding, as seen
as being raised from the water,
which is a Kan system--
tilted?
And it's often repeatedly
shown up in numerous examples
as a tilted object.
There's actually a good
point why it is tilted.
The early Book of Change, for
those of you who lived through
in the 1960s would know that
I Ching, a Book of Change,
would give you the description
that this ding vessel is
something that gets rid
of the stale passings
and taking the
fresh good things.
So essentially, this
is a trope for saying
that this is a
vessel that allows
you to change your
breath, especially
if you consider that--
here's a passage.
So the cauldron is overthrown,
its feet turned up,
but there will be
advantage in getting
rid of what is bad in it.
So for the practitioner, a
breathing exercise that could
use this concept to regulate
their breath and consider--
especially in the time
of seasonal change--
you get rid of the stale breath,
you're taking the fresh breath,
and that goes on through
your internal vessel.
And that's why you could
see that it's tilted,
and there's also the
dragon sticking out.
The dragon is normally
on this rising yang
associated with the spring,
and so on and so forth.
And what is that bubble thing?
Well, one possible meaning is
that if you look at this also
from a painted, or rather
contemporary painted coffin,
you will see this young figure
with this antlered archer
shooting at the bubble.
It's held by this bird, so the
meaning is actually clear--
essentially the one who
killed the stale breaths.
And so this bird is going
through this breathing exercise
and thereby gaining vitality.
So if we then examine where
this cauldron scene is located
in this entire
program, you could
see that it is right
between spring and summer,
and so everything
starts to make sense.
All right, so we
kind of explained
what the cauldron is
doing there, and now let's
move to the acrobatics.
If the vessel scene is about the
springtime growth of the yang
energy--
or also known as the
growing yang energy--
the acrobatic scene pertains
to the autumn sequence.
It's part of the
autumn sequence,
and it pertains to the
growth of that yin energy.
And that is the case here.
But the question is
why is the acrobatics
associated with the autumn?
And this actually, is a result
of historical development.
Autumn-- so essentially,
what I'm saying
is that these two
things, even though they
have seasonal association,
but the real point
is that they are each associated
with a particular kind
of energy.
This is a rather a
growing yang energy,
and this is a
growing yin energy.
So the question is why is this
growing yin energy, this autumn
energy, associated
with acrobatics?
Initially, autumn is a time--
commonly considered
the time associated
with a withering killer
spirit, or breath
that strips the tree of leaves.
So the fact that we observe
in autumn the wind stripped
the tree of leaves, you
know that this breath
is kind of killer.
And so early calendrical
text basing an autumn
for military action,
since human affairs
are expected to conform to
the cyclical rhythm of nature.
If nature kills in
autumn, then human beings
should do so accordingly.
In other words, if you
read these ritual manuals,
basically say that you are not
allowed to wage war in spring
because that's a
time when life begins
and absolutely forbidden.
So yes, if you want to wage
war, do it in the autumn.
So military action or
martial exercise often
signify an autumn scene.
Over time, the military
exercise, or martial exercise,
evolved into a variety show.
I guess people-- most
people-- don't like war.
So they are accordingly
replaced by acrobats
as a signature scene of autumn.
So in either case, the
growth yin energy in autumn
is the real point.
Now, if we are to
diagram this movement
of growing yang and growing yin
energies, we would have this.
The growing yang ascends,
the growing yin descends.
And if you are to correlate
them to seasonal terms,
as early Chinese
are prone to do,
we end up having the
winter as a nadir,
and the summer as the apex.
The dispersion of energies,
a condition of falling apart,
spells death in early
Chinese imagination.
Conversely, concentration
of energies and convergence
of growing yin and
growing yang energies
spell life and vitality.
For that reason, this decorative
scene of a whole vessel
is rather suggestive.
You could see that this
is the autumn scene,
therefore it signifies
growing yin energy.
And you can only go down, and
that gets you to the winter.
And in the meantime,
these mulberry tree
scenes and so forth--
archery scenes associated
with the growing yang,
the spring, therefore
you can go up
and you can see that the hot
mating scene signifying summer.
So you could see that the
cycle is actually disrupted.
Each growing yang
breath and growing yin
breath go separate ways.
And that it actually
is a bad situation
because you don't
want that to happen--
because essentially what that
situation means is death.
But for the design
of the vessel they
want to make sure that things
don't go wrong, don't go back.
So they created this
middle band which
are this part of the scene--
actually, is the autumn scene,
and this is the spring scene.
Oh, I'm sorry.
This is the spring scene,
and this is the autumn scene.
So the point is to artificially
let two yin and yang breaths
to come together,
therefore creating life.
And that is a perfect sort
of cosmological model,
as you can see, even though
it takes seasonal cycle
as it's a natural model.
But you could see it's
actually quite artificial.
It's a way of, you might
say, going against nature
to some extent because
it's working against how
the seasonal cycle would go.
So you could see that
essentially that's
a condition of vitality.
This is the ideal
situation you want to have.
And if we go back
to our sarcophagus
we see the cauldron
and acrobatics scenes,
and then we know
what they really
pertain to is to have both the
growing yang and growing yin
energies facing each other.
And sure enough, you will
have the summer scene
with two birds and everything.
So that is essentially the
larger underlying design.
And again, if we
return to our pit,
you see essentially the
same, the presence of the two
components-- the
growing yang and growing
yin coming together.
So what you see here
is that the pairing
of the cauldron
and the acrobatics
suggest a staged symbolic
effort aimed at revitalization
by bringing together growing
yang and growing yin energies.
Now, a cross reference
to our sarcophagus scene
suggests that indeed,
that is the case.
You have three figures in
the upper temple scene,
as you can see, two of them
seated with raising the finger
and pointing downward, with
another one bringing two things
together.
So this gesture essentially
is heaven, and this is earth.
So they're praying both
to heaven and earth.
And this figure essentially
is a hypothetical, imaginative
figure that can force--
that can bring these two forces,
the heaven and earth, together.
And if we notice this
whole gesture of pointing,
and we go to our pit, we find
all these figures are doing--
a lot of these figures
doing the same thing.
They raise their fingers, which
is again, quite suggestive.
And this pit actually is
also suggestive in that you
have all these figures
arrayed in pairs,
and one stout figure
facing one skinny figure.
And that has puzzled scholars.
Why is it?
So my theory is that probably
the skinny figure stands
for the growing yang, and
the stout figure stands
for the growing yin, and they
represent different energy
forces and that coming together.
And to further
testify my theory,
you can see from a sarcophagus a
carving of two fingers likewise
with the upper bare torso
trying to raise this cauldron--
this vessel--
up in a way that
these figures seem
to collaborate in this
whole ritual process,
as you can see here.
And keeping in mind
pairing, it's also--
we can see how the same
logic works out in slightly
different iconography.
So from another sarcophagus you
see a cauldron in the middle,
and you see the dragon, and
you see the tiger, respectively
representing growing
yin and growing yang.
So by this stage
I'm sure you know
very well just how this
whole vocabulary, how
this whole mechanism, works.
Essentially, they're coming
together, merging their breaths
in this vessel.
And lo and behold, this
vessel starts to come alive.
You can see the pair
of eyes opening.
Essentially it means
that life is happening
in this vessel, which
is another way of saying
that this vessel itself is
a sort of energy cooker,
and things go in and life
becomes possible there.
It's a kind of incubator.
So again, don't take
tiger, dragon literally.
All things in Chinese vocabulary
is more relational rather
than referential, so
what matters is really
how binary work and can be
replaced by similar binaries.
So essentially, they
all mean the same thing.
So in a way it is really sort
of a computational system.
So you can replace all these
phenomena along the same line
so long as you keep
that pairing and going.
But I want to call your
attention specifically
to this pair, mercury
and lead, which
is very essential to the
alchemy in the ancient Chinese
experiment.
Alchemy, mercury, lead are
the key components that
would make some kind of physical
transformation possible,
or so they imagine.
Then it also become the way,
even if they couldn't quite
succeed in real life,
they will imagine
certain physiological process
as a result of this interaction
between the mercury and lead.
They believe that human
body actually has these two
components-- mercury and lead.
And having them interact
would get your body going.
So with that in mind, let's turn
to this paragraph by Sima Quin.
The Records of the
Grand Historian
were written around 100 BC.
Pretty much all the
literature if you go out
to read everything about
the First Emperor tomb,
everyone cites this passage
because it's so well known.
And that's also
how we understand,
or we infer that the
emperor's tomb is all about.
So essentially it says
the emperor was interred
at this mountain and
the workers dug down
to the third layer of
underground springs
and mercury was used to fashion
imitations of the 100 rivers.
Above were
representative of heaven,
below representative of earth.
Now, this paragraph had
been endlessly quoted
and misunderstood, mainly
because it's very misleading.
In fact, if you watch
all these documentaries,
they basically say that
inside the emperor's tomb
is a representation of China
with all the Yellow River
or Huang He River below,
and with heaven above.
I actually question that
because of the notion
of having a geopolitical map
as the object of representation
was very alien in early times.
Actually, we do have a
very curious situation
that mercury is important
in tombs, and only
in two civilizations,
so far as I know,
that deploy the use of mercury
was present or practiced.
One is in China,
another is in Mexico.
So in Mexico, a
third century BC tomb
you have the mercury
in a lower level.
By any case, this
passage becomes
the source for
modern video-makers
to imagine the inside.
Then they imagine this mercury
floating around and all that.
What is wrong with
this is that it posits
a static cosmological model.
Earth is forever Earth,
heaven is forever.
And that is totally
wrong because the dynamic
of the Chinese
cosmological model
is precisely that
nothing stays what it is.
It always goes up
and down, changes.
So if we read one
of the early sources
you will see what I mean.
The breath of earth ascends
on high and that of heaven
descends below.
That music-- and that
is considered music
where you have the harmonious
action of heaven and earth
coming together.
So this is more of a
proper understanding
of early cosmological model, and
that music model, that harmony,
of how breaths would often
constantly circulate and change
places, so one day's earthly
breath becomes next day's
heavenly breath, so
nothing's locked into space.
Now, this music model,
this harmony, this flow,
is really the key, master key.
So I think the more
fitting physical model
that will help you to imagine
what the early Chinese cosmos
is is this duck-shaped object.
This is actually the
cosmological model
because it's painted
on both sides--
lack of painting both sides.
On the one side is a
drum with a dragon.
The other side is
a bell and chimes.
So what they mean is
that the drum simulates
the thunder of the
spring, waking up
all the hibernating creatures
from the long slumber
of winter.
And they're interacting
with the bell that
is associated with
autumn, and together they
can make the life
happen, as you can see,
which is this
pattern-- actually,
probably subtlety refers to
this copulation in spring.
And sure enough, we
find the same pattern
appearing on that
vessel from the pit
I've been talking about.
And it also found
both below and above,
which means that this copulation
of two kind of breaths
is constantly going on.
So essentially, we see
that this vessel is really
sort of a mixture of energy,
is an incubator of life.
And it's also for
good reason that it
has some kind of
conceptual relationship
to this imaginary
model in the body
where you could see that there
is the ding vessel at the lower
region constantly cooking,
heating up, and generating
energy.
And as it generates
energy, the system
also posits some kind of
vehicle or wheeled thing,
even though this
is a [INAUDIBLE].
But sometimes they used
an image of actual vehicle
to carry this energy through
the spinal cord up to the brain
region.
And in the meantime,
the whole thing
is imagined as a natural
environment, natural ecology,
which is another way of
saying that the body is not
to be taken seriously.
It's really that ecology, that
system, that ultimately counts.
So that calls our
attention to this vehicle,
what in Chinese
terms called a "river
carriage," in special terms.
So this pairing of the vessel
and the wheeled carriage
is very important
for our purpose.
As you can see here
on the sarcophagus
you have the vehicle
and the cauldron,
and what is referred
to is really
this kind of relationship.
So could it be that we
have similar correlation,
or connection, between a
cauldron and the vehicle?
Here, I'm really experimenting
so no one has thought that way.
I'm probably out
on a limb on this,
but still I want
to explore further.
And I think there's
a strong case
to be made that
there's a connection--
a possible connection there.
So this bronze carriage,
half life-size,
which meant that it is
produced for afterlife use--
so this actually is a
good occasion for us
to kind of step back and reflect
on the whole history of the use
of vehicles in afterlife.
The use of vehicles in
China goes way back,
as you can see from
this burial site
where you see the
human figure and you
see the horses harnessed.
And that dates back to
1250 BC, Shang Dynasty.
And if we take a
step further back,
we essentially have
a whole history of--
we have a big picture view of
how the whole humankind evolved
in civilizational terms with
the increased use of vehicles.
By the way, the use of chariot
is really the key technology
that enables the--
I would say-- the
pre-Indo-European cultures
to wipe out the other
three ancient civilizations
with this.
Around-- I guess the key
years around 1600 BC--
that was a time when this
thing really happened,
this revolution really happened.
So I have here a
little animation.
As you can see, this is China.
And so this chart indicates
the passage of time.
And we can see how it--
and also as a
vehicle goes around,
it's actually remarkable,
though the word associated
with vehicle remained
rather consistent
and gets spread around.
If you look at how, in
terms of linguistic entity,
that means our current
modern sense of the vehicle,
it goes rather consistently.
And I think the
Chinese word [CHINESE]
is probably derived from
the old Indic word "chakra."
It sounds more or less similar.
But the mystery really is--
this is fairly straightforward--
but the mystery really
is what do people bury the
vehicle in the tomb for?
Why are they doing it?
So you can see we
have two examples that
will probably
basically illustrate
how the scholars think
about this issue.
One is that you have the
real life-size vehicle as
exemplified from the
tomb of Tutankhamen.
It's decorated with the
precious objects and so forth.
So that the minute people
or scholars see this kind
of life-size vehicle
highly decorated--
and the knee-jerk reaction
is that it [INAUDIBLE]
status, social status.
It is a status symbol.
And then this, from
Hungary, is a small model
of a vehicle crudely made.
And then the explanation-- the
common explanation is that it
is transport to afterlife.
So currently, basically
these two kind of theories.
Fortunately, our
case here in China,
we have known enough
of the context
to actually go deeper than
just these two theories.
And we can literally have a
more refined understanding--
at least in the Chinese
case, I can't speak for other
cultures--
what the vehicle is
doing in the barrel.
So recall that you have the
vessel, the inner vessel,
and you have the
vehicle going, and if we
think about what's going
on here the same logic
may be operative.
And it's especially in
regard to this sarcophagus.
So the connection between
the two sets of works
actually runs deeper.
The back of the
carriage has this door,
and this door is decorated.
And what is remarkable is that
it has two different kinds
of patterns.
One is the so-called
[INAUDIBLE] pattern,
or wavy pattern, which
typically associated
with spring, with growing yang.
And the other is this
[INAUDIBLE] pattern,
which is typically
associated with yin,
growing yin force with autumn.
And they often are
brought together
in some kind of obviously
revitalizing intent or scheme.
Now, if you think I'm reading
too much, we have evidence.
Similar pairing shows
up the wavy pattern
and the [INAUDIBLE] pattern.
So obviously, it's a common
vocabulary-- form of vocabulary
that they use.
And if we again look at a
more contemporary design,
you see there
again the cauldron.
You see the tiger, dragon.
By now you know it's growing
yin force, growing yang force
coming together.
And then if we examine
their decorative pattern
you see similar wavy pattern
and the [INAUDIBLE] pattern
interacting.
So essentially, it should
come as no surprise
that this [INAUDIBLE]
pattern appears
on the surface of
these acrobats.
Too bad we don't have
many survivings of it
because a lot of them
just deteriorate.
And so we at least have enough
fragments to give us a sense
that this is what's going on.
So it all comes down
to seasonal cycles.
It all comes down
to what a season can
mean in an extended way.
So if we hold on to
this line of thinking,
we find that we
are able to expand
a lot about this tomb site.
So according to the early
texts, in springtime
you do the following things.
You try to capture geese
as a gift for weddings
and because geese means
young, and all that.
So you renew your breath
through overturned vessels
that get rid of the
stale taking the fresh.
You have this
spring inauguration,
according to ritual
manual, in east suburb.
And let's see if it
applies to the tomb site.
You have the capture of
geese, you have the vessel,
you have the inauguration
of the spring to the east.
And that also explains why is it
that the terracotta army is so
far away from the tomb mound.
It's actually one mile.
The point is actually
that it is the suburb.
It is the east suburb to
just [INAUDIBLE] east suburb.
And to [INAUDIBLE] you
have to be really far away.
Then how do you then
explain the fact
that they are not
wearing helmets,
whereas helmets are kept away?
I think the point is this.
They want to have
the army so that you
would have the gravitas of
the solemnity of the ritual
occasion because it's the
inauguration of the spring.
But if you have them
wear the helmets,
that means they are
in military action.
And military action is
not allowed in spring.
It's a big no, no.
So they have to take
away their helmets
so that they have
enough gravitas,
but then they
don't want to cause
any association with autumn,
with military action.
So all the helmets
are left actually
in the company of the ding
vessel, which actually makes
sense because the ding vessel
is associated with the spring,
and this is with autumn,
and they come together
as they generate life.
Now, a lot of what
I'm saying relies
on this man named Lu Buwei.
Under his leadership, they
compiled this massive work,
and from that
massive work there's
this prescription of what you
do in different seasons, what
we call "monthly ordinance."
That was Lu Buwei's creation--
or his team's creation.
Now, he's important
in a number of ways.
So here's a little
interesting recap
of how he helped first
emperor, or the young man,
to gain the power
and unify China.
So it all takes us
back to this map,
and he's from this place called
a Wei state, as you can see.
And then he found that
there's a young prince, Yiren,
who was a prince of Qin,
but was held hostage in Zhao
because the Qinians all want
to be at peace with [INAUDIBLE]
so they exchange hostage.
So this poor man, young
prince, was sent there.
So Lu Buwei was
actually a merchant.
He made a huge amount
of money and he's
one of our forerunner
of capitalist.
So he thought that he wanted
to invest his fortune--
monetary fortune--
into political fortune.
So he spotted this
prince and then he said,
OK, I'm going to make
a killing out of this.
And so he basically
cozied up to him
and they really become friends.
But this young man fell
in love with his consort
and Lu Buwei very generously
said, all right, you take her.
So essentially, they
married and then
their son is the
future first emperor.
So sure enough, they
went back to Qin
and eventually
succeeded in the throne
and that was the
rest of history.
Now, what is interesting is that
after they assume the power,
Lu Buwei rekindled
his passion, or flames
according to some theory,
with the woman, Lady Zhao.
But then he was also
fearful that people
might catch him doing that, or
that close alliance with him
and her wouldn't be very
good, so he introduced
a very virile man named
Lao Ai as a fake eunuch
into the harem, and
where he and she
they struck up a
passionate romance
and actually bore two children.
And I'm telling this actually
for good, serious reason
because this virile man,
according to the early source,
is so potent--
his male potency--
that it is said
that he could use his erected
male organ to cause the wheel
to turn around.
Now, that's really a strange
way of showing male potency.
And I think this is actually
a complete misunderstanding
of what essentially was
initially a breathing exercise.
So according to the ritual
manual of breathing exercises--
even the later manual-- but
at least point out the early
practice is that as the fire,
energy gets into that inner
vessel, the male practitioner--
a lot of these manuals written
for man--
the male practitioner will
feel the sensation of erection.
It's actually clearly stated.
So whether this is metaphoric
or real, we don't know.
And then you are supposed
to transport that energy.
Instead of letting
go of it, you're
supposed to transfer the energy
through the spinal cord up
to the brain region.
So the point therefore, is
that this so-called erection
actually has a lot
to do with the will,
so with that may be where things
got misunderstood in this case.
And sure enough, we
always have evidence.
So the-- people laugh, so
you already see what I see--
and there's a wavy
pattern actually.
There's a wavy pattern.
So archaeologists
actually insist that this
is a cap for this vehicle axle.
I see something more,
but I wasn't quite sure.
But you see you laugh, that
kind of confirmed my impression.
In fact, that already--
even though if it's
truly a vehicle axle cap,
it certainly didn't take
much for the designer
to think, or take the
next step, which is this.
They did find this near
contemporary bronze male organ
in tombs.
And scholars, curators,
or exhibitions--
actually now there's one on
display in San Francisco Art
Museum--
and if you read
the press interview
they typically talk about the
afterlife, sexing, the tomb,
and all that.
It actually doesn't quite
add up because a lot of these
were found in tombs where the
husband and wife and not buried
together.
So in any case I
think what may happen
is that it was meant as part
of this revitalization regimen
where all these pieces are in
place to reenact and simulate,
artificially simulate a
process, not actually doing it.
No one's doing it,
I mean, in the tomb.
So we then know
how it came about.
But more importantly
the point I want
to end up with is that
now we understand actually
why early Chinese often
imagine heaven as a wheel.
So did the first emperor, or
the spirit of the first emperor
go to heaven?
No, it's not going anywhere.
The crucial thing is really to
keep the Chi energy circulating
in this vital ecology.
The entire tomb complex
is that ecology.
The army is here to provide
the growing yang energy needed
for the conjugation of
energies yin and yang, heavenly
and earthly forces.
Even though there is a concept
of heaven in early China,
there is really no
"up there" there,
certainly not in a static way.
Heaven is a flow
in all directions.
Thank you.